if you plan on going into the fourth
Avengers movie totally spoiler free then
we wish you the best of luck but if you
just can't wait until the movie comes
out to try and figure out what happens
we've got some of the most compelling
rumors around it up right here it's been
a while since we've seen Captain America
in charge of a full-fledged team of
Avengers since the events of Civil War
he's been running around in the shadows
doing his work as a fugitive with a
small loyal group but fanos appears to
be just what the Marvel Cinematic
Universe needs to let bygones be bygones
and get the band back together in a big
way a purportedly leaked image from the
marketing materials for the 4th Avengers
film seems to reveal carp leading a new
team of Avengers in an ultimate battle
against the mad Titan if it's real then
the revamp team will consist of Iron Man
Black Widow Hulk Hawkeye and Thor along
with war machine and Scott Lang's
ant-man also present as newcomer Captain
Marvel guardians of the galaxy member
rocket and nebula daughter of Thanos the
image also reveals cap to have cleaned
up since his grungy ur days and infinity
war clean shaven and back in a star
spangled suit it doesn't show his
classic shield but with a lineup like
this does he really even need it those
familiar with Marvel Comics have
probably been anticipating the arrival
of the alien Scrolls in the MCU for some
time now according to an Avengers 4
rumor started by Jeremy Conrad our MCU
cosmic Nick Fury has also been waiting
for the humanoid shapeshifters to show
up which is exactly what he thought was
happening during the infinity war
post-credit tag as Conrad tells it when
people started vanishing after Thanos
snapped his fingers furious soon the
scrolls were to blame and called on
Carol Danvers for help
Conrad also claims a Hawkeye will be
involved in the scroll storyline hunting
down Yakuza in Tokyo who are secretly
Scrolls in disguise it sounds like a
pretty great way for him to make us come
back after sitting things out of the
family farm clearly retirement doesn't
suit you got tired of shooting golf well
I played 18 shot 18
this can't seem to miss rumors that
Avengers force plots will heavily
involve time travel happen out in the
wild ever since leaked photos first
emerged of the movie recreating scenes
from the first Avengers it's a pretty
compelling rumor and that man in the
wasp might tell us everything we need to
know about how it's going to go down
while the small-scale sequel mostly did
its own thing
the mid-credits scene dropped a huge
clue about how the Avengers may win the
infinity war in the scene Scott Lang
returns to the quantum realm being
advised by the first wife but not to get
stuck in a time vortex while he's in
there as the credits team reveals Fano
says fateful snappa takes place while
Scott is still inside the quantum realm
leaving him stuck inside the tiny world
with no one alive to get him out to
escape his apparent doom it seems
plausible that sans mom will risk
exiting the dimension through one of
those time vortexes where will he end up
based on the fact that a significantly
older actress has been cast on the role
of Scott's daughter Cassie it sounds
like he's probably going to the future
at one point practically since the
release of infinity war there's been a
theory that the seemingly dead Avengers
are actually trapped in a pocket world
inside of the mysterious soulstone
there's plenty of precedent for the
frere in Marvel Comics the soul gem
houses the soul world a pocket dimension
that acts as a kind of purgatory and we
may have already seen the place some
believe that the orange colored
dreamlike scene in which Santos talks to
young Gamora
after her death in infinity war may take
place inside the stone with her death
having been crucial to Thanos getting
the stone in the first place but if this
is all true
how will the Living Avengers get into
the soul world and how will the snapped
ones get outs that we do not know
speaking on a panel at the 2018 Austin
Film Festival Marvel Studios producer
Michael Grillo revealed that one Doctor
Strange actor is unexpectedly returning
to the MCU speaking about the difficulty
in scheduling actors for the massive
production Grillo seemed to let it slip
that the ancient one would be returning
for Avengers 4 in some capacity
discussing time constraints a guerrilla
reportedly said when we got Tilda
Swinton as she was just a one-day
availability if you don't remember the
ancient one appeared to be fatally
wounded at her own
events of dr. strange passing on after
one last pep talk to the sorcerer
supreme considering her decisive looking
death and her established knowledge of
time travel she's probably coming back
as part of a time trouble plot as a
former guardian of the time stone who
was alive for thousands of years
she could have vital Intel for the
surviving Avengers even if she doesn't
go head-to-head with fan OHS herself one
of the biggest surprises and Avengers
infinity war was a return of Red Skull
and it appears as though its upcoming
sequel will bring another Captain
America villain back with a bang
speaking to the UFC and filtered podcast
in October 2018 crossbones actor Frank
Grillo revealed that the deadly assassin
and Hydra agent was going to be making
an appearance and Avengers 4 but how
after all crossbones died when he tried
to blow himself up on Steve Rogers right
throwing caution to the wind Grillo said
he makes an appearance in the next
Avengers movie but it's a flashback I'm
allowed to say whatever I want because
I'm never doing another Marvel movie
I'm 117 years old brillo later tried to
walk back his comments but the damage
was already done it all adds up to a
pretty clear suggestion about where
destructor and the infinity war story is
going
but if time-travel really is where the
story is going why Earth's Mightiest
Heroes need to revisit this particular
villain remains to be seen
[Music]